bueno principal problema de que tenemos
ahorita es con elevación del nivel del
mar el mar se está elevando consecuencia
del deshielo de los glaciares el
deshielo de los de los casquetes polares
y también por la propia capacidad del
mar de aumentar su volumen a la medida
que aumenta la temperatura el principal
efecto que vamos a tener Es que esto va
a ser un ciclo de que va un forzamiento
positivo al calentamiento climático para
verlo de una manera bien simple una
superficie Blanca refleja es el hielo
pero ahora que no hay hielo esto no va a
reflejar entonces la mayor mayor
cantidad de calor se va a quedar dentro
de la atmósfera Y eso vamos entrando en
un ciclo que puede decirse un feedback
positivo que vamos a tener consecuencias
mucho más graves principalmente en lo
que es elevación de nivel del mar
cambios en la utilidad pesquera en el
acceso a la pesquerías y eventualmente
también hay otras consecuencias más
geopolíticas porque al quedar libre de
hielo el el Polo también va a haber
Competencia por los recursos pesqueros y
también Competencia por el acceso y el
tráfico marítimo entonces no es un
escenario definitivamente
muy positivo para el planeta y más allá
de la actividad humana en cuanto a la
vida Marina No solo en el Ártico sino en
todo el planeta Qué afectaciones podrían
verse
a veces el ejemplo más emblemático como
siempre hemos vivido son los osos
polares y como ellos muchas criaturas
que requieren del hielo para
establecerse este hielo cuando informe
se va mezclando con el agua Marina
genera condiciones para el florecimiento
de muchas especies que son la base de
las cadenas alimenticias que resultan en
las pesquerías pues probablemente vamos
a tener problemas con muchas especies
ahora en estado vulnerable o en peligro
que probablemente no van a poder
reproducirse o completar su ciclo para
poder llegar a una siguiente generación
estamos hablando del Ártico pero el
continente Antártico también sufre el
deshielo por la emergencia climática que
cambios están viendo ya allí Cómo están
afectando a los ecosistemas de países
como Argentina o chile por citar algunos
de los más cercanos a la Antártico en la
Antártida en la región latinoamericana
la gran diferencia es que la antártida
tiene un continente bajo el hielo
entonces conforme Se va deshielando se
va rompiendo los glaciares que es una
situación que hemos visto con bastante
frecuencia en los medios en los últimos
años va exponiéndose más y más
superficie de tierra la tierra es oscura
y hacer oscura
calor y ese calor es